JEREMY HOFFMAN: So,
I'm Jeremy Hoffman.
I'm a software engineer here.
I've lived and worked in
Mountain View for six years.
And for most of that time,
I didn't give much thought
to the factors shaping
the Bay Area, why housing
is where it is and
not in other places
and why jobs are where they
are, and not in other places,
and how people get from
those jobs to work.
Why do people drive instead
of walking, or biking,
or taking public transit?
Until, luckily
for me this June I
attended a public forum here in
Mountain View where Egon here
spoke about all the factors
that shape housing and transit
and really opened my
eyes to all this stuff.
And I thought his information
and his analysis and insights
were so great that I got
really excited about sharing it
with more people.
So thank you so much for coming.
I think this is going
to be a great talk.
Egon has a lot of great
information for us.
I'll give you a little bit
of a background about Egon.
He graduated Phi Beta Kappa
from Swarthmore College,
earned a master's degree in
city and regional planning
from UC Berkeley's College
of Environmental Design.
For five years he worked
with ICF International,
where he advised
cities and regions
on economic development,
everywhere from California
to Louisiana, Ohio, Nigeria,
Canada, Argentina, Bosnia.
And now Egon is regional
planning director up
in San Francisco at
the organization SPUR.
He writes reports and
he's done policy studies
about regional planning,
economic development, land use
planning, transportation,
high speed rail in California.
We're really lucky to
have him here today.
So please join me in welcoming
to Google Egon Terplan.
[APPLAUSE]
EGON TERPLAN: Thank
you very much.
Thank you very much, Jeremy.
Thank you very much
Google for having me here.
Can everyone hear me fine
in the back of the room?
Great.
It's really a
pleasure to be here.
I actually haven't been at
Google in a couple of years
since I took my students.
I was teaching a
San Jose State up,
and we met with Kevin
Mathy and his team.
And it was, I think, a time
when a bunch of the new bikes
were coming in.
So it's great to be back.
I'm glad a lot of you came out.
Just as a quick starting
point, how many people here
in the room live
in Mountain View,
live in the town
of Mountain View?
How about, how many people
here live in Palo Alto?
How about anywhere else
in Santa Clara county?
So a lot of you.
And how many people live north,
live in San Mateo county?
So a smaller number, all right.
That's tells us a
little bit of something.
Not about you, but
San Mateo county
doesn't have a tremendous
amount of new housing.
How about San Francisco?
How many people live
in San Francisco?
OK, a healthy amount as well.
Well, good.
So actually, anywhere else?
East Bay, beyond?
OK, so a smaller smattering.
So you represent a spectrum
of different places
within the region.
We're going to try to touch
on a number of those things
here now.
So I'm Egon Terplan,
as Jeremy said,
the regional planning
director at SPUR.
I'm going to say a
word to about SPUR,
but just as a starting
point, it's fun
to be here talking
about these issues now.
And as I was
reflecting upon this,
has anyone here heard
of AnnaLee Saxenian?
Ooh, quiet in the room.
So AnnaLee Saxenian's
one of the great writers
on the history of Silicon
Valley and wrote a classic book
comparing Silicon Valley
with Boston's Route 128,
and tried to understand,
why did Silicon Valley grow
the way it did?
And it's very
interesting, about a bunch
of factors in how
companies are structured.
But she had written
her master's thesis
in the early '80s saying,
Silicon Valley's over.
It is too expensive.
It is too congested.
No one's going to
come here anymore,
and no one's going
to start companies.
And that was right
before the Apple II Plus.
She was wrong, clearly.
The question, though, is
at what point do the issues
with housing affordability,
underinvestment
and transportation,
some of the challenges
with the local government
policy making on land use become
really profound,
competitive factors that
affect the regional economy?
And I don't think we
know quite the answer,
but we're certainly
getting to some
of the moments that
could be choking points.
So what I'm going to do
today is very quickly
say a word or two about SPUR,
who we are as an organization,
and then go through
a number of pieces,
a little bit on the growth
context of the Bay Area.
When I say the region,
I mean the Bay Area.
I don't mean the South
Bay or Silicon Valley.
I mean the nine-county Bay Area.
Then talk about the
sort of problems
that we're confronting.
Some of the answers about
why the problems exist,
and then some solutions.
All of that in about-- I don't
know, let's see, 27 minutes?--
so that we have some chance to
hear from some other folks here
that are engaged
on local issues,
as well as take your questions
for the conversation.
So quickly, who is SPUR?
So SPUR is an
organization that is
based in San Francisco
and San Jose.
This is our urban center in
San Francisco, been around
for 100 years.
We're an urban
civic group focused
on good planning
and good government.
We write policy
papers on a wide range
of issues facing
cities and regions.
How many people here have
heard of SPUR before?
A healthy number.
Well, those of you
that haven't, now you
know a little bit about SPUR.
I encourage you to come.
Come to the urban center in San
Francisco on Mission Street.
We have a number of
activities there.
I will show you a photograph
of our San Jose office
as well, where we also have
a number of lunchtime events
and forums.
That's the room where
we have discussions
in the San Francisco
office as well.
We engage people in a variety
of ways through research--
we write our papers--
through education, in going
out and talking to
people, and engaging them,
and through advocacy
as well at times.
Our work-- our offices, as we
will see in just a moment--
there's the San Francisco
Urban Center on Mission Street.
We have a San Jose one
located on First Street,
right on the Light rail line.
So when you come to downtown
San Jose, stop by there as well.
And we're now moving
in a direction
of considering opening
an office in Oakland.
And part of the idea is, these
are the three central cities
of the Bay Area-- San Francisco,
San Jose, and Oakland.
What happens in those central
cities shapes the region.
It doesn't shape all
of it-- and we're
going to talk some about the
other cities in the Bay Area
today-- but those
three central cities
have a very big
responsibility for what
happens within the region.
So let me talk about that
regional context just
for a moment.
And as I said, the region
is the nine-county Bay Area.
We are right now in the midst
of considering a long range
plan that was
adopted a year ago.
And the long range
plan is trying
to understand, how do we
accommodate the next two
million people in population?
This is the expected growth.
You can see the
projections out to 2040
across each of the counties.
So that's the
growth in population
that we're expecting.
But we're trying to
do so in a way that
reduces per capita
greenhouse gas emissions.
That means that the new
people have to drive less.
They have to have a
different behavior on average
from the people that have
been here historically.
And this is part
of a state mandate
to respond to climate
change through changing
how we live, changing where
our workplaces are, houses are,
and how we travel around.
And so you can
see, we're supposed
to reduce it by 15% in 2035.
But part of that overall
vision is considering,
how do we accommodate housing
for workers at all income
levels?
Meaning, building
housing for people
who can afford the
market rate homes
as well as people that
don't have as much money
and can't afford the price
of the market rate home.
And anyone who's been in
the rental market, who's
been in the housing market,
understands how expensive
that specific market rate is.
That is the regional context
of the broad based thing.
And the vision is to try to put
that growth closer and closer
to the existing
transit infrastructure.
So first of all,
the job goals are
to get 38% of the jobs in
the three central cities.
And then you can see the list
of the top 15 jurisdictions
where the growth might go.
So notice Palo Alto, which is
ranked number 6 in job growth,
and Mountain View as 15.
This is the job
growth projections.
When we turn to housing,
interestingly Palo Alto
disappears from
the top 15 cities
of where housing
growth might go.
Now Mountain View is
still there as 15th,
but Palo Alto is
not there as well.
And that starts to tell
you something, a little bit
about the relationship between
job growth and housing,
that the places
that are assuming
a tremendous amount of job
growth perhaps, I would argue,
have a little bit
of a responsibility
also to try to find some
housing for the workers that
are coming there.
So this data exists for cities
all across the entire region.
So let's understand and
drill down a little bit.
We'll take questions at
the end, so mark them down.
Let's drill down a little
bit into the problems
that are associated with this.
Housing costs too much.
It's very expensive.
OK, that's not a
particular surprise.
But what you start
see here is, this
is just the San Francisco
median-priced home.
You can see how we're getting
further and further away
from California and the
federal figure in terms
of housing prices.
And actually, just comparing
to a city like Portland,
Portland's certainly much
cheaper than the Bay Area
and much cheaper
than San Francisco.
But you can see that it was much
closer back in the mid '90s.
Again, the difference is
getting greater between some
of the Bay Area cities
and other places.
Right now we're at
a particular moment
where properties, when
they're put on the market,
are sold extremely quickly.
So Oakland, San Francisco,
and San Jose right there--
and this is earlier
this year, it's
gotten even more accelerated in
the past couple of months-- not
only are the home prices growing
faster than almost anywhere
else, but they're
practically staying
on the market for
hardly any time.
So the difference between
this region and other parts
of the United States
is getting greater
on this particular account.
Let's think a little bit about
some of the economic factors
though that are also under play.
And we're doing a
lot of work right now
on this question of access
to middle wage opportunities
in the region.
And what we have,
like many regions
we have growth in jobs
at the high end, growth
in jobs at the low end,
but a much smaller middle.
And so one of the profound
challenges-- and we
say this because people are
surprised often that over 36%
of all workers today
earn less than $18
an hour in the Bay Area.
And that figure is in
fact likely to grow,
because the opportunities
to move those people
to jobs that pay $25
an hour, $28 an hour
is getting harder because
there's fewer of those jobs.
Were working on it.
We're trying to consider it.
And one of the great
ways, actually,
to create some of
those middle wage jobs
has to do with infrastructure
investment, housing
construction, other
development related to that.
But right now, that's
a specific problem,
and it's an economic problem.
There's also an
environment broadly,
nationally where
there's an increase
in the number of renters.
And that's a trend that's
happened since the housing
bubble burst.
A lot of people are choosing
to rent instead of to own.
On some national data,
there are renters
that are facing income declines.
So that's been a concern.
It's not a concern across
the board with all renters,
but that's something
that people are
starting to see in some places.
But the issue is, all workers
across the income spectrum
are feeling this crunch,
are paying more for housing.
And that's a big,
big consideration
across lots of households.
And I'm sure everybody here
who's confronted the housing
market recently has
seen that as well.
The last piece of
the problem puzzle
is just the fact that
primarily most people
get to and from work by driving.
And so what that means is
that the roads are congested.
And congestion's a good
thing to the extent
that it shows a lot of activity
and people want to get around.
A place that has
no congestion might
mean there's not
a strong economy
and during the
recession there was
less congestion in this region.
But when most people are
getting around driving,
that certainly has an
impact on overall mobility.
And for people that don't
have access to an automobile,
that's a challenge.
So let's get to
some of the answers.
Why is it that
housing's so expensive?
First most obvious one is we're
not building enough housing.
You would think it's simple.
But going back to
the 1950s to 1980s,
that was the big
growth of the Bay Area.
That was the postwar boom.
That was when this region really
became an industrial powerhouse
first during World War II, the
early rise of Silicon Valley,
the postwar boom in
the East Bay with a lot
of the manufacturing, and the
conversion of San Francisco
into a corporate
headquarters and environment.
Silicon Valley then, of course,
became a corporate headquarters
environment as well,
and we responded
by building lots of housing.
We then also had a
lot of job growth.
That all turned
around about 1980.
And yes, there's been
job growth since then.
The percent growth
slowed down dramatically.
But one of the
factors is actually
that we didn't continue
to produce as much housing
after 1980.
And this little
thing called prop
13-- everyone heard
of prop 13 before?
Some of you haven't,
which is fine.
It was passed in the late
'70s to essentially freeze
property taxes at
the point of sale.
What it effectively did was,
for many local governments,
they lost a tremendous
amount of revenue.
And it changed how they thought
about new development going
forward.
And a lot of them
didn't think housing
would pay as much
in taxes as jobs.
And so it led a
lot of communities
to not favor housing as
much and why a lot of them
really like shopping centers.
Because shopping centers
bring sales taxes.
Office buildings add
property taxes to the roles,
but it's really shopping
centers, auto malls,
those are the things that fund
a lot of local government.
So that changed in
California in the late '70s.
And since then we've
really entered this period
of not producing
as much housing.
And that's the world
that we're in today.
So you can see it particularly
pronounced in San Francisco.
And we've estimated
that 5,000 units a year
is about what San Francisco
could do, or ought to be doing.
And you can see that San
Francisco has effectively
never reached that.
It was sort of a
blip for the moment,
but those were authorized,
not actually constructed.
It's growing again
now, but this is
something where, over
time, your housing problems
don't happen in one year.
They're chronic when over
decades you're underproducing.
This is probably one of
the most important points
though to make.
I said we don't build
enough, but supply matters.
And it really matters
when you compare us
to the rest of the country.
There are essentially two kinds
of inexpensive housing markets
in the United States,
places with not very strong
economies-- let's say
politely-- and places
that build a lot of housing.
There's no place with
a strong economy that
doesn't build a lot of housing.
Look at where we are.
San Francisco, San Jose,
Oakland, and then near us
are Honolulu and Orange County.
These are outliers on
a national context.
So it really is a key
factor in where we go.
And what you're seeing
is how much was built.
Over to the left, we
haven't built a lot.
And up here is the meeting
asking price per square foot
on a comparative basis.
Looking just at one
year as a snapshot,
I said that's not a
best way to do it,
but just to
understand last year.
The biggest place
building housing
is San Jose, then San Francisco
and interestingly enough,
Dublin, Dublin in the East Bay.
If you go out there, there's
a Bart Station there.
You see a whole number
of five story apartment
buildings going up.
Now, they can't on their own
solve the regional housing
challenge because they're
in a housing market
where people are
picking and choosing.
But when one city
does it and you
don't see other cities
of that scale doing it,
that's what adds up to
the regional challenge.
And you can see
Mountain View produced
37 housing units in 2013
and Palo Alto less than 100.
Very small numbers.
Now, some of this is a blip
because a particular project
might come forward when
the calendar year changes.
But the idea is that the bulk
of the housing production's
not happening in
cities that have
had a significant
amount of job growth.
There's also a challenge when we
look at the low income housing,
or the housing where people that
can't afford the market price.
Very little of that
has been built.
And those of you that might
follow the redevelopment
system, we eliminated
redevelopment in California.
That was a major source of
funding for housing for people
that couldn't afford
market rate housing.
It's gone.
So that side of it has
also been exacerbated
in the last couple of years.
So part two, why is
housing so expensive
when we make it
difficult to add housing?
How do we make it
Well, let's go
back in time again
a little bit to
that postwar era.
We're coming out, and
there was this thing
called urban renewal that
happened in a number of cities
in a lot of neighborhoods
throughout San Francisco
and throughout Oakland.
Parts of downtown San Jose
were torn out, were destroyed.
So housing units were lost.
It happened in whole
numbers of neighborhoods
throughout the city, but it also
happened in the downtown core.
Anyone recognize this?
It's now the Yerba Buena
Center by the Moscone Center
right there in downtown
on Mission Street.
The church is there.
So this was the building
of it, but this had been,
formerly, housing.
All gone.
So there's a whole
history on urban renewal.
We don't need to get into that.
I'm making a simple point that
a tremendous number of housing
units were lost during
that period of time.
What that also led to,
in part was a backlash
to growth and development.
And this was particularly
stark in San Francisco,
where there were attempts to try
to cap the heights of buildings
in the city to four
or five stories.
And in fact after
the early '70s,
residential heights
in San Francisco
were almost universally
capped at 40 feet, which
is four stories, with a few
exceptions-- one of them being
downtown-- and that had
to do with the building
at the foot of Van Ness
called the Fontana Towers.
And if you ever see
it, these sort of two
partially curved modernist
towers facing right
by Ghirardelli Square,
right by the waterfront.
So this backlash to growth
is still with us today,
and it was a response
to a number of changes.
But just from a
political perspective,
there was a ballot
measure in San Francisco
to protect the waterfront
was the name of it.
It led to the fact
that now anything
that needs to be built
on the waterfront
has to go through
a ballot measure.
So that's now a new law
in San Francisco that
is going to have a direct effect
on the number of housing units
that could be built on various
portions of the waterfront,
around the Giants' stadium.
But this isn't just a
San Francisco issue.
This backlash to
growth is something
that happens in a
number of places.
And Palo Alto voters
in 2013 passed
something called Measure
D where they rejected
a specific project, an
affordable senior housing
project in Palo Alto.
So that one specific event
didn't transform the housing
market, but these
kinds of decisions
are happening all the time.
Whether they're
at the ballot box,
or they're at the
planning commission,
or they're at a City
Council hearing,
those decisions are the
ones in the aggregate that
make it very difficult
to add housing.
And each community seems to have
a different reason for doing
it, but they all come somehow
in the direction of saying, no.
Some places will say, well,
we like our neighborhood
character.
That's going to change our
neighborhood character.
We don't want that.
Other places say, well, we don't
want to see the traffic go up.
It's going to make
the streets too full.
They won't be safe.
Others say, well, it's going
to impact city services.
Where's the water
going to come from?
We have to come up
with new sewer systems.
And there's a point.
It's not that-- these aren't
entirely without validity.
It's just that the aggregate
of all of these terms--
concerns about
gentrification, concerns
about a definition of urban to
suburban, which was something
in Marin County
that had them think
they had to approve things
of a certain density.
The aggregate of
all these changes
leads to saying no to growth.
And then we get to the
regulatory process.
There are a lot of smart people
in the room who can probably
do fantastic things.
I would challenge you
to be able to build
a building through
the planning process,
because it's not
just actually-- if it
were this easy to
follow the little path
and go through it, that
would be one thing.
But then mixed on top
of this, of course,
is the political process
and the series of issues
that you have to get through.
So it's complicated
and it's expensive.
We did a little back of
the envelope calculation
of what it would cost
to build new units.
And this was just
the starting point
for an 80-square foot
unit in San Francisco.
You start with the
cost of land, $120,000,
construction cost $240,000.
$300 a square foot's
probably conservative.
There's a subsidy for the
below market rate units
if you're doing
a certain number.
And then the other pieces,
the permits and fees,
selling expenses.
And that's not taking into
account risk, that's not
taking into account
the bank issues,
a whole variety of things.
It's expensive to build housing.
There's also then the
issue of part three
about jobs and housing.
And this is one that's a
little bit complicated.
Communities prefer
jobs to housing.
But to the extent that
they're supportive of jobs--
many places are--
they're often not
as supportive of
jobs in the core
of their cities around transit.
So if you look at just
some of the numbers here,
jurisdictions like jobs,
housing not so much.
Santa Clara county, 926,000
jobs, 631,000 housing units.
And it's flipped in some
of the East Bay communities
that are more housing rich.
If you look out to Contra Costa
county, it's different there.
So part of this I mentioned
before, after Prop 13,
the perception is that
jobs bring in more in taxes
and workers consume
less in city services.
Those of you that don't
live in Mountain View
aren't consuming much in
Mountain View services--
fire, police, library
services, parks.
You're here most of the
time during the day,
and the same is true across job
centers throughout the region.
The other issue is that tax
receipts are inequitably
distributed.
Just look over here at
Palo Alto, San Jose,
and Santa Clara.
Palo Alto and Santa
Clara are job rich.
They have high tax
receipts per capita.
San Jose is housing
rich, and they
have low tax
receipts per capita.
And this affects the
politics of those places,
because San Jose is really
trying to figure out
how to bring in jobs
so they can become
more in balance themselves.
And this is ultimately the
point of all of these things
I'm trying to raise is
that we're in this together
as a region.
This is not Palo Alto's
issue or San Jose's issue.
It's the Bay Area's issue.
But individual
cities are the ones
that are making the
calls about what
happens at their communities.
So this is the new
SurveyMonkey building
across the street from
the Palo Alto Caltrain
station in downtown.
It's a lovely building.
It's only four stories.
Now, it's a nice building.
I'm posing this
somewhat rhetorically.
I have an opinion,
leave it to you.
Is four stories
sufficient density
directly around transit?
And I heard from Adina
that they actually
were required to add
significantly more parking
then they wanted to.
But only 30% of the people
arrive there by car.
So they have all these
extra parking spaces
that they were forced
to build which drives up
the cost of the building.
So you can get people,
when their jobs are
right next to transit a lot of
them are going to take transit.
But the communities are limiting
the amount of job space.
And this is the most
expensive real estate
market in the region
is downtown Palo Alto.
But that limit on zoning is also
here in downtown Mountain View.
And it's at almost every single
one of the Caltrain stops up
and down the peninsula and
throughout the South Bay.
You can't come in and
plop a million square foot
office building right
in the downtown,
even though those
communities want jobs.
And then this fall, Menlo Park's
going to have another ballot
measure about limiting
growth, almost exclusively
limiting office growth
in their downtown core.
It's going to affect
retail as well.
It doesn't directly
affect housing so much,
but part of the issue
is these communities
are trying to put a
stop on lots of things
that they don't want to become--
which, for Menlo Park's case,
I guess is Sunnyvale.
That's the thing.
So part of this is that it's
not that much of a surprise
that a lot of the major firms,
like where we're sitting now,
aren't located directly
around transit.
That the communities
that these companies
are in that provide jobs and
that have these contributions
to the region simply
wouldn't permit this amount
of commercial square footage
in their downtown core,
although there are
some regional benefits
of being directly
around transit.
And that's a
fundamental challenge
that we face right there.
The other side
though is when you
talk to people about
transit-oriented development.
Who here has heart that term,
transit-oriented development?
Do you think of housing
with maybe a coffee shop
underneath when
you hear that term?
That's sort of what
transit-oriented development
has become.
That's great.
That's a wonderful idea.
We should have a lot more
of that in our region.
But transit-oriented
development could also
be office space in a
core next to a rail stop.
That's also an
equally valid idea
for transit-oriented
development.
And when we look at
the data on this,
it shows that people are
more likely to take transit
if their job is right
next to that transit.
Now, if their housing and
their job is next to transit,
they're even more likely.
But job alone is more
important than just housing.
And what this means is that what
happens right around rail stops
in particular is extremely
important from a job
perspective, from a
regional perspective.
And this has not
changed over time.
This has really been
that way for a long time.
So throughout the
Bay Area, most jobs
are located near
freeway off-ramps
and only a quarter of jobs
are around regional rail.
And so some of that are a
series of historical factors
with highways and other things.
But some of those are those
local zoning decisions.
And where it's light
or orange is in fact
where there's available
space to build.
There's not a lot of density
around those particular rail
stops.
We also know from
an income analysis
that people are traveling
more to get to better jobs.
So better regional mobility is,
in fact, a way to going back
to the question of how
do we connect lower wage
workers to good jobs,
better regional mobility
gets them that way.
And this is a trend
across the whole region.
But the problem is that we
have this transit system
throughout the Bay Area
that's not quite a system.
It's 27 basically
independent operators.
And this is probably a
nice way of how it looks.
This looks like they all
reasonably connect together.
We've been trying to
show this in a way that
really makes the problem worse.
And it looks relatively even.
But the problem
with that evenness
is that we don't live
just in one county.
Think of San Mateo and
Santa Clara counties.
They bleed together.
We're part of one
urbanized corridor.
Now, people may not like
the word "urbanized."
Let's just call it
one corridor where
people are traveling
back and forth.
But we don't have a
transit system that
allows people to support
that, so it becomes
a big regional challenge if
you're trying to get from, say,
Walnut Creek to here, or lots
of trips within the Bay Area.
So we know most people
drive alone to work.
And in fact, you guys are on
here in this particular chart.
The drive alone
rate to this campus
is almost comparable to
downtown San Francisco.
So location is not
an entirely-- you
can, through a lot of the
programs Google has offered,
get to a drive alone rate
which is similar to the most
transit-oriented environments.
It requires the shuttle programs
and the transportation demand
management that you guys have
done here, which are fabulous.
But most of the
rest of the region
doesn't have that, doesn't
have those types of amenities.
So on a regional scale, most
people are driving to work.
And so we have this.
We have people driving
long distances,
we have growing congestion,
lots of in-commuting.
The other side that it's getting
worse with a capacity issue
is on transit.
And Caltrain-- anyone here that
rides Caltrain has seen it,
it's growing and growing.
And that's fabulous, but we
need to invest in it in order
to make sure it's going
to be around there.
And investment is
a bunch of factors.
And if you have questions,
Adina can answer those really
at the end.
But it's around
electrification, and new cars,
and train control systems
that make it work.
And BART has the same issue.
So the regional rail
systems in the Bay Area
are very competitive
with the automobile.
I'll mention shuttles briefly,
just say what about shuttles.
Shuttles are not the
problem, they're the symptom.
It's really about
local land use,
as I've been trying to say, that
the local land use decisions
that limit housing
near where people work,
limit jobs in the
dense cores of places,
the shuttles become a very
effective solution to that.
Yes, it's about employee
recruitment and retention,
and it's great in that regard.
But from a land use
perspective, that's
at least how I see
this particular issue.
So that last mile problem
is what we have so much of.
Those red splotches are office
buildings near rail transit
and the blue ones are those
that are more than a half mile.
And that's the geography
of this region.
And it's not going to
fundamentally change.
What's going to change is the
density of those office spaces,
the extent to which housing is
allowed in those office spaces,
and the extent to
which those rail places
become more of job centers
and have more housing around.
Those are the factors
that we can really
think about changing.
So let's quickly get to
a couple of solutions
so we can be optimistic and
then take your questions.
One of them is
around the provision
of affordable housing.
This is not something where just
building housing of any kind
is going to entirely solve it.
Lots of people will
not be able to afford
market price
housing at any rate.
So we need to do
that, and there's
a challenge in this
region because, as I said,
redevelopment's gone and the
sources of that have gone away.
And it's very expensive to
build affordable housing.
So you can see the cost
of 1,000 homes, 10,000,
and 100,000 homes.
So we have to come up with
new sources that broaden this
so it's not just new
development that's
paying for affordable housing.
So that's one piece of
the particular puzzle.
We're also thinking about
renters and existing tenants.
And there are some places that
have good tenant protections
and others don't.
And that's an important
piece of the puzzle as well.
The next piece his
neighborhood planning.
So thinking about where
growth can take place,
doing a neighborhood
planning process
so places are allowed to grow.
And part of that relates to
reforming how we build housing
and how we permit
it, but the places
that have gone through
good planning processes
are able to grow.
These are some of the big
areas in San Francisco.
And that mark at Octavia, that
green one, those 6,000 units,
a lot of those are
happening right now.
This is the job growth.
But I wanted to get to some
photographs of what we're
seeing the growth happen in San
Francisco along Market Street.
That is the product of
neighborhood planning.
So as each building
comes forward,
people aren't protesting
it because the agreements
were made long before.
It's difficult, it's
expensive, but ultimately it
leads to the creation of lots
of development and buildings
like this which
have zero parking.
And this is actually an
affordable housing project
developed by David Baker.
So beautiful things
that are contributing
to the overall community there.
The third piece then relates
to allowing more growth
in some of the existing
communities that we have.
This thing called
secondary units
so people can have
a backyard unit
that they add to their home.
You could add a third to
the San Francisco housing
count by doing it.
And this is the zoning map
for the City of Mountain View.
And if you can see this
light yellowish color here,
that's single
family residential.
That means nothing
but one single home.
So you can't have
a secondary unit.
So individual
communities-- if we
looked at the communities that
are around here or Palo Alto,
you name it-- San
Francisco, too.
Almost the entire western
half of San Francisco
has limitations like this.
It means you can't add
apartment buildings,
you can't add secondary units.
That is limiting the total
availability of housing.
So I bet a lot of
you are actually
renting homes, single family
homes, in some of these places
and sharing them with roommates.
That becomes a
solution when you don't
have that flexibility
in the zoning code.
It goes back to the
powers that we've
given to cities to
police themselves.
The next solution is to
upzone around transit.
I mentioned this.
We can allow people
to build more
on top of the existing
transit stations.
There are places like North
Berkeley where nothing
has been built
since BART went in.
BART comes in, it's
underground, and you've
got this lovely Bart station.
Great regional accessibility and
zero new housing in 40 years.
And this might be this
way for another 25 years,
because there's nothing to
compel Berkeley as a city
and the residents
of that community
to allow housing on
those parking lots.
And think about how
many parking lots
are around a lot of
transit stations.
Think about all of
those as opportunities
where people could
have existing homes.
Then there's the job question
around regional transit.
In downtown San Francisco
in the trans Bay zoning
is a place where there's
a significant amount
of dense employment
that's going in around
what hopes to be the northern
terminus of high speed
rail and Caltrain.
Some of those towers
are residential as well,
but those kinds of spots are
important for development.
Then there's new
locations, places
where we haven't had
housing historically.
We can add.
Let me get to a
clearer version of that
which is Treasure Island.
This is a place that's
planned for thousands
of units of housing.
Yes, there is sea level rise.
We're aware of that.
This is going to be
planned hopefully
with enough of a
buffer around that.
But that's a Bay
Area issue as well.
Sea level rise is not
unique to Treasure Island.
It's not going to be unique to
the Hunter's Point shipyards.
But again, these
are places where
there's a significant
amount of growth that can,
and we're moving forward
with developing them.
Then there's the question
of the corporate campus.
So we're in certainly
a corporate campus.
And there's been a lot of
thinking here about the vision.
This is the proposed
Samsung campus
that's currently
under construction
on San Jose on
North First Street.
But the traditional model
of the building surrounded
by parking lots, in some ways,
we've moved away from that.
And so what we want to
see are environments
that could be transformative.
I don't know if anyone
happened to catch these.
Someone went through
and said, well,
what if we added all
the housing that's
being demanded by the jobs
that are growing at some
of these campuses and put
them at the parking lots
around them?
That's what it would look like.
So that's iTown.
Think Cupertino
would go for that?
And then how about this one?
You think Googlers would go
for this one around Google?
Now those are
residential towers.
This is a thought experiment.
This is not proposed
zoning or planning ideas.
It's simply saying that there's
a significant amount of demand
for housing.
It's going to go somewhere.
And that somewhere
doesn't have to be
five feet away,
though ideally it
could be for some number
of the population.
But it should be in a
place that's accessible,
and it should be in a place
that people can get to easily.
The suburban retrofit piece
is also a part of that.
And that's a version of that.
And there's other developments
that are being proposed.
This is another one on North
First Street that's again
trying to remake the
traditional corporate campus,
to bring it closer
to the street,
to make it more
walkable, to make it
like it's part of
a neighborhood--
not just something you
drive to, you park your car,
and you can't get around.
I think this environment here
is much lovelier than most
of the office parks
throughout the valley.
There's bicycles,
you can get around.
A lot of the other
environments don't have that.
They're more of an isolated pod.
And so this is just a vision
of a direction it could go.
And there is not yet
a tenant for this.
And they're searching for
one, but they at least
have a concept in place.
So just a couple more
quick points, and then we
want to open it up.
Regionalism is key.
We don't do this alone.
We are not in isolation
from each other.
We've saved the open
space in the Bay Area
as a great product
of regionalism.
Golden Gate National
Recreation Area,
these are things
that are actions
of regional responsibility.
So too will sea level
rise be the kind of issue
that we're going to have
to work on as a region.
It touches every community,
and these questions
of housing and transportation
as well are part of that.
San Mateo county
is trying to work
across multiple
jurisdictions to figure out
how much housing to grow.
It doesn't mean they're any
more supportive of housing,
but at least they
have a process where
those cities talk to each other.
And Santa Clara county is going
to copy a version of that,
and we'll see the
direction that goes.
Those are promising steps,
and one of the levers
we have as a region
is to say, we
won't invest as
much transportation
money in a place
that's not going
to grow in concert with
the regional goals.
So lastly, the very
last point on this
then is about transportation.
We don't have this integrated
regional transit system.
That's something we certainly
should strive towards.
That is what our
competitor regions have.
The places at this region the
Bay Area is competing with
have that.
They also have more housing.
So those are some of
the factors that we
want to make sure we work on.
So just quickly in summary,
this has taken a long time
to create.
You would say that this
is a chronic problem.
This is not a temporary problem.
It's not going to be immediate,
but there's a lot of-- it's
important to think
regionally in this,
but the solutions in many
of this take place locally.
So with that I think we're
going to hear from some folks
here on some of
the local issues.
And then I look forward
to your questions.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
JEREMY HOFFMAN: Thanks, Egon.
So I just want to
talk briefly about how
local issues play into this.
These sorts of
decisions, these are
playing out right now
in your city councils,
in your city halls, in
your local elections.
I've gotten involved this year.
There was a group I got
involved with called Campaign
for a Balanced Mountain View
that really has been drawing
light on the jobs housing
balance in Mountain View.
And it's been really
heartening for me
to see how the City Council
members, they're our neighbors.
They do care about the
opinions of the residents.
And it's actually very
possible and plausible
to influence them and let them
know what our concerns are
and what our
priorities should be.
And also, I'd like to
introduce Eric Rosenblum.
He's on the planning
commission in Palo Alto.
Would you like to
say a few words?
ERIC ROSENBLUM: Yeah,
just very quickly.
First, again thank you Egon.
And great to see a good turnout.
So I'm Eric Rosenblum.
I was a Googler until
about two years ago.
And I was always
interested in these issues,
but never knew how
to get involved
and didn't even know if
I could get involved.
It turns out, it's
not that hard.
The people that
oppose all growth
are not necessarily
that numerous,
but they're extremely
well-organized.
And it turns out that if you
bring a slightly different
mindset, I went from being
completely uninformed to being
a planning commissioner for
the city of Palo Alto, helped
to form a group called
paloaltoforward.com.
So if you'd like
to educate yourself
more about some local issues
and how to get involved,
I encourage you to go
and read up a little bit.
And feel free to contact me,
Jeremy can find me easily.
JEREMY HOFFMAN:
And I'd also like
to thank Adina Levin who is
with the Friends of Caltrain
organization that helped
organize Egon's talk
that introduced me to him.
Do you want to say a few words?
ADINA LEVIN: Sure.
And there are some really
important regional decisions
being made about how to
modernize Caltrain and then how
to fund it.
Greencaltrain.com
is the website,
and this is one of these
regional efforts where
citizen participation
will be helpful.
And don't underestimate
at all the power
of citizen participation.
The things that Jeremy and
Eric have been doing even
in the last few months
have been changing
what's going on in our cities.
So you have more power
here than you know.
JEREMY HOFFMAN: So I
encourage everyone,
read your local papers.
These issues are covered.
The debates, get
involved, learn more.
And now, we'd like to
open up the floor for Q&A.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So I noticed you have the
projections going forward
something like 25 or 30
years for not just jobs
but also housing.
How do you take
legislation into account
when you project how
many housing units are
going to be built
in a given city?
EGON TERPLAN: So the
housing projections
are-- there are two factors.
One of them is looking
at how much California's
going to grow as
a state, and then
apportioning that to the region.
And then within the region,
it's a little bit more
of a political process down
on the jurisdictional level.
So in terms of legislation, it's
thinking about factors like,
where is there zone
capacity within cities?
What cities have done
planning for this?
But it is not thinking
about, is there
going to be some legislative
change in 15 years?
Is there a piece of legislation
you're thinking about?
AUDIENCE: No, I
was just wondering
EGON TERPLAN: But so it's a
political process in part.
And so you may hear about
RHNA, if you get involved,
the Regional Housing
Needs Allocation.
But it becomes a question
of Palo Alto saying, well,
we don't want to add
1,000 units, 2,000,
whatever the number is
for their particular city,
because then they
have to find locations
where they would plan for it.
And they can be
sued if they don't
identify locations for it.
But they can't be sued
if they don't approve it
in the same way.
So the teeth aren't
quite so strong.
I think Adina has a
comment on this too.
ADINA LEVIN: The type
of legislation in a city
is called a general plan
or a comprehensive plan.
And the type of
planning for an area
is called a precise
plan or a specific plan.
And that's where the city makes
the law for how much housing
and offices are
allowed to be built.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
I'm curious, do you think
that development that's
going to encourage people to
live closer to their employers
is an important part of
solving these problems,
or if orienting
things towards transit
makes that less important?
EGON TERPLAN: That's
a great question.
So I think both are essential.
But just for example,
let's say there
was going to be a
significant amount
of residential development
in the North Bayshore Area
here in Mountain
View around Google.
Well, some number of the people
living in those apartment units
would probably work here
or would work close by.
They would make that choice,
so it's incredibly important.
It is not the entirety
of the solution.
We also have to invest
in regional transit,
because people are
moving around the region.
This is a region that
has a lot of mobility,
and people change jobs.
So both factors are important,
but you can very clearly
demonstrate that housing
close to people's jobs
will reduce the
amount they drive.
AUDIENCE: So it seems
like a lot of these issues
are coming that are
governmental in nature,
whether it's permits,
or measures, or zoning.
Now that this is becoming
a more hot button issue,
have you seen changes happening
at the ballots what people are
voting for?
Or is it still sort of
too new, and this November
is what we should
keep our eye on,
and what's happening at
the local government level?
EGON TERPLAN: That's
a great question.
Well, this has been
going on for a long time.
So some of the votes to restrict
these things go back decades.
San Francisco, for example,
a place that I was arguing
is a great place to add
jobs, it restricts the amount
of office space on an
annual basis going back
to the voters in the 1980s.
You can't build more than a
couple office buildings a year.
So I think that it is one where
there's growing interest in it.
And some of the examples of
these folks getting involved
is a good sign.
It looks like, Adina, do
you want to make a comment?
AUDIENCE: Are there
any relevant elections
coming up in Mountain
View and Palo Alto?
JEREMY HOFFMAN: There are
relevant elections coming up.
So the way Mountain
View City Council works
is there are seven seats elected
at large across Mountain View.
In alternate every two years,
either four or three candidates
are elected for four year terms.
So three new
candidates are going
to be elected this November.
Google here-- there are
a lot of candidate forums
in Mountain View and before
November 4 election day.
And you should all register
to vote in your town.
One of the candidate
forums will be here
at Google on October 15.
It'll be over at
Charlie's at 4:00 PM.
So if you want to hear the
nine candidates running
for three seats and their take
on the problems facing Mountain
View, you should
definitely come to that.
Again, that's October 15.
ERIC ROSENBLUM: Jeremy, I wanted
to add just quickly also, I
thought it was a great
question about what
has happened locally.
I'll give two examples.
One's very positive,
and one I would say
is negative in the
context of this talk.
A small group started talking
to Palo Alto about what's
called TDM, so Transportation
Demand Management.
So that's what you all
enjoy here at Google.
The shuttles that
take you to work,
the good work that Kevin
Mathy's team does for all of you
but most towns don't have.
And actually, just a small group
of people coming into the City
Council got Palo Alto
to start adopting
this measure for
all of downtown.
So they've just
begun that process.
Hugely impactful, didn't
take that much work.
On the flip side, this
election in Palo Alto
is likely to result in
a slate of candidates
that their platform
is no growth.
There's been a major backlash.
And so it's an important
election coming up.
This is apparently
fairly unprecedented.
But however you feel about the
issue, one side or the other,
there are some major
changes happening
on both sides of the issue.
AUDIENCE: For the
housing problems,
one of the solutions
you mentioned
is more low income housing
and more rent control.
I was under the
impression that one
of the causes of
the housing crisis
is the rent control laws
that make a tenant not
want to move even though their
job is not in San Francisco,
but they have a well below
market rate apartment.
And the homeowners want to
get out of the rental market,
and fewer and fewer
properties are on the market.
And some of them
are even converted
to non-residential
space, because it's hard
being a homeowner of
a rental property.
Can you comment on that?
EGON TERPLAN: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So in part, this is an
incredibly complex situation.
And there's people at
many different income
levels in our region.
And I think what I'm
trying to acknowledge
is you can't just come up
with an answer that solves it
for the people who could afford
the market price housing.
A lot of people cannot afford
the market price housing,
and there's a variety of
strategies within that.
What you're getting
at is the question
of what's the impact
of rent control
specifically on some places.
There's only been a few cities
in the region-- San Francisco,
Berkeley, Oakland to a lesser
extent, San Jose to a lesser
extent-- that have any
form of rent control.
So within those
places, yeah, there's
been some of those impacts.
But by and large, the question
of neighborhood stability
and housing stability
is an important one.
But it's a much longer--
it's a good question to ask,
but I think the broad housing
solution needs to make sure
that we have housing for
people that can't afford
the current cost
of housing as well.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you think
the stagnation exists
because homeowners
don't have incentives
to vote for this
growth, because there's
no economic incentive for them
to lose value on their house?
And how can we move
forward with that?
EGON TERPLAN: And local
homeowners don't actually
have an incentive on the
impact, the fiscal impact,
of the decisions.
Their property
taxes stay frozen.
And so the extent
that their community--
take San Jose as an example--
is looking for more revenue
to add to it's city services.
The individual homeowner
actually who's been in a home
for a long period
of time doesn't
have to contribute to that.
AUDIENCE: But what about
the price of their home?
EGON TERPLAN: I think there's
a lot of misperceptions
about the price of their home
in terms of changes to things.
And one thing I would
point out, that if people
are going to build
more densely, that's
a sign of rising land values.
So there's not a
direct relationship
between increasing
density in a community
and the impact on
housing prices.
So a large part of
that is perception.
But a lot of it's people just
don't like change of any kind.
AUDIENCE: I have
a quick question.
So we have seen
how you have shown
the projection of 15% growth.
I was thinking, can we think of
50% more capacity in the sense
we come to a place for 9
hours and commute for 2 hours.
So those 12 hours
we're outside home.
So house occupancy right
now is 50% in that sense.
And population
also, they are also
thinking in terms of 24 hour
banking, 24 hour hospital,
24 hour services.
So in that sense, can we extend
one more shift in working
and distribute people
in that accordingly
so that our roads are
not that congested,
our houses are not
that congested?
EGON TERPLAN: So
you're suggesting
that people might take
the homes that they're not
in during the day and
have people sleep in them?
AUDIENCE: The same
family can distribute
who works in the day, who
works in the night, who
is with the kids during the
day, who is with the kids
during the night rather than
just going to some daycare.
EGON TERPLAN: That's the reality
of how low income people can
survive in the Bay Area.
What you have just
described is what
happens every day in
communities over this region.
Someone works as
a janitor, someone
stays home with the kids,
someone works at night,
someone works during the day.
Is it by the force of policy
to try to impose that?
Unlikely.
I think you can
encourage companies
to be more flexible in their
workforce and other phenomena.
But I think that what
you're getting at
is probably more about a
kind of social and cultural
transformation that
would need to happen.
But it's creative,
and it's important.
AUDIENCE: The current
housing crisis
and the policies
that gave rise to it
are related to
the deurbanization
of American cities in the recent
past and the social tumult
and migrations that resulted--
white flight suburbanization,
deindustrialization, et cetera.
Is the area sufficiently
past those social ills?
Or is some of the
resistance to growth
still drawing on
those old wounds?
EGON TERPLAN: Wow, very
complex, important question.
Short answer is yes.
We're a product of
our recent past.
The deindustrialization affected
large parts of the East Bay.
And this is why I was really
trying to make a point
and think about
the income factor.
Just think about the
Bay Area for a moment.
Historically, you had a
lot of suburban migration.
Like lots of regions, we
had lower income populations
living in older communities in
parts of San Francisco, parts
of Oakland, parts
of the East Bay.
That has changed.
So some of the pressures you are
seeing, particularly in Oakland
right now, are very
different from the pattern
of deindustrialization,
and decentralization,
and moving out.
And you're going to have
political pressure as prices
go up and people perceive that
they're going to be pushed out,
or in reality their
children won't necessarily
be able to afford the
rents as they go up.
So I think these
are ones that we
want to get in front
of as a region.
And the answer is to think
about this more broadly
to make sure we
build enough housing,
but these are a lot of complex
issues in that question.
ADINA LEVIN: Back in that
generation, suburbs were cool,
cities were uncool.
If you had a choice, you
moved to the suburbs.
So the earlier
conversation about what
do current homeowners
think, they're thinking what
makes my place great
is that it's suburban.
Walking and biking and transit
are what uncool people do.
And the current generation
of younger adults
think really differently.
There's a cultural
shift going on.
AUDIENCE: I've been reading
a lot about the shuttle pilot
program in San Francisco
and Facebook's doing a lot
with housing development
around Menlo Park.
Is there a point
at which you think
these companies that are
growing really rapidly
have more of a
responsibility to step
into with public/private
partnerships?
Or is that happening already,
and is it-- to what extent?
EGON TERPLAN: That's
a good question.
I'd love for Kevin and
the transportation folks
to address that.
But I think the
reality is-- and I
think Google recognizes this--
Caltrain is fundamentally
important to the
region, and it's
fundamentally important to
making all of these pieces
go together.
The shuttles that are
being run are great,
but they're a part
of a solution.
And so to the extent
that you all as people
working here get involved
with issues that are happening
with Caltrain and make sure
that Caltrain's successful,
as well as thinking--
when you're
saying public/private
partnerships,
there's the public investment
in the transit system.
But there could be
some sort of scenario
where you have more
people riding Caltrain,
they get off in
Mountain View, and then
you're running more express
feeder buses-- public, private,
shuttles, whatever
kind-- from downtown
Mountain View to this area.
And in fact, I think some of
the planning for Shoreline
Boulevard coming here
would facilitate that.
So that's the kind
of direction we
need to go in a
number of these things
is to make sure some of
those regional trunk lines
have enough capacity,
so a lot of people
can move big distances.
And then public/private
partnerships,
a variety of mechanisms to get
people the last couple of miles
ultimately to their destination.
So I really hope all of
you can get involved.
I didn't mention before, I also
want to recognize my colleague
Leah Toeniskoetter in
the back of the room who
runs our San Jose office.
So those of you who live
in Santa Clara county,
want to continue these kinds of
conversations in the South Bay,
talk to her, show up
at our San Jose office.
Get involved with
Friends of Caltrain
or think about these are the
kinds of issues where these
are really being talked about.
JEREMY HOFFMAN: Thank
you all for coming.
And thank you, Egon.
EGON TERPLAN: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]